I just happened to written story told to
me about one of those old soldiers 35
years ago which many years later found
its mark with the National Theatre I'm
so pleased now that young people can
read a story about that war that they
can connect with very very strongly I
mean essentially for them this is a
story about a horse
who loves a boy and a boy who knows a
horse and they are parted at the
beginning of that war drunken father who
sells the horse off we shall be together
again
so the young boy now a teenager goes
looking for him and of course all the
children want is they want the horse to
find his best friend in life and his
best to try and find him but they do it
through this war because I wanted to
find a way of telling this story which
was about all sides there are many
stories written about the British the
French the Germans but they tend to be
in separate stories and he was an
opportunity to have Joey tell the story
through the eyes first of all the
British farm horse leaving his little
village in Devon my village where I now
live being taken off to the war trained
up as a cavalry horse being captured by
Germans then seeing a war through German
eyes because all the years that the
German people talking to him and then he
winters on a French farm so he sees this
war from all sides and what do you
understand from that you understand that
war is about the universal suffering
doesn't matter who you are what color
your uniform or what the cause is the
people who fight it and the people of
whose land it's fought through whose
houses and villages and towns it's for
they're the ones are doing the suffering
and that's the same now as it was then
in fact I would say it's almost more so
because the weapons have become even
more destructive and of course these
wars are brought into our our sitting
rooms and for kids their kids will turn
their phones that turn their iPads and
they'll say these kids being carried out
of buildings in Syria you know and they
need to understand what this war thing
is then it's got nothing to do with
where they might live in
in Battersea or in Birmingham you know
this is a whole other world and this
Joey story enables them to see what
happens when the world goes mad and
people fight instead of talk so for
children to be understanding of the
harsh realities of war for you is it
finding the human element in these
stories yes because remembrance has to
be personal I think this is where the
trouble with remembrance is it is yes we
have these important symbols they are
involved and we have the figures you
know we know how many millions of people
died on British like the fridge beside
that German sign it's all their history
classroom exactly only now the opinions
came over from India from Africa this
was a world war it's enough to say if
it's a world war for a young for anyone
you can't get your head around that you
just cannot get your head around the
degree of suffering that went on so the
only thing I think is is to tell stories
personal stories now they can be true
they can be about your great uncle your
great great-grandfather or you can do
what I do is you base it on truth and
then you take it a stage further and you
make a fiction of it and there's a
different kind of truth in fiction and
what's good about that is the child can
then identify with the soldier because
otherwise all those soldiers out there
now and they're all gone anyone who
knows them all knew them is gone as well
so effectively they're all unknown
soldiers now at all unknown soldiers so
the only way to get to know one is to
know a story
what is the poppy mean to you my uncle
Peter was killed at age 21 in the RAF in
the Second World War so to me he was a
photograph on a mantelpiece and nothing
more and but you know when you're young
and you see your mother cry will you
don't forget it and my mother was not a
crying woman generally at all but on
November the 11th and on uncle Peters
birthday she was beside herself with
grief and was like that till the end of
her life so what did I learn from that I
learned that this man a young man he was
21 he was an actor and he acted at
Stratford he was the whole life ahead of
him never became a father never became a
grandfather
like a great-grandfather I mean it
didn't have this chance to fulfill
himself and that touches me really
touches me and I can't help but notice
that behind your red poppy you wear the
white poppy why is it important for you
to have those on side by side because I
know that the vast majority of these men
and women who died died cuz they like
fighting a war there wasn't about glory
it they were fighting for our peace you
know there and the reason we were sent
here in the theater we can make any play
we like and we can say what we like on
stage and it's because we have our
freedom it's important to remember that
the nearly a million of them died and
they died in their heads I'm not making
this up my own quite convinced they died
for mum dad home sweetheart children and
for peace does it disappoint you that
there is a poppy debate as to whether
one should wear a red poppy or a white
poppy there does seem to be a
conversation at the moment over wearing
poppies and given what you've talked
about about men and women dying in their
fight for freedom yeah and that includes
freedom of expression I just wonder what
you make about the poppy debate does it
disappoint you no no I think that's fun
the wonderful things about this country
when we would disagree we're disagree
but we try and I think until recently
anyway mostly try to respect the other
person's point of view because this is a
free country we can wear a white poppy
or a green pop years some people were
purple probably further for animals some
people don't wear them at all and that's
fine that's absolutely fine and I think
what problem we get into I think is this
business of judging other people how are
you
be marking the centenary this weekend
well and actually here I should be
coming here on November the 11th and I
shall be
seeing these wonderful people play out
this play of someone once called display
the greatest anthem to peace they'd ever
seen in a in a theatre so I shall be
here and I think I'm going to go to this
to this and in the Albert Hall they have
this some service of remembrance
festival of remembrance and I should be
there for the first time because I wrote
a peaceful one of the veterans to read
out at the beginning of the ceremony and
they invited me to go along so I'm gonna
go and see that so she would take a lot
of remembering this remembrance they
okay Michael my pocket really really
interesting to talk to you thank you for
speak to you so much got you so nice
thank you thank you